Why does Islam promote a simpler life and favor poverty?
Muslims are less bothered to chase money.
But why? How else is success defined?
Well, to give this answer this question to 007, it's not necessarily true that we prefer
poverty. The prophet peace be upon him also said the strong believer is more beloved and
better better and more beloved to Allah than the weak believer in all things in intellect
in knowledge in wealth in physical
uh fitness and strength in all things the strong is better than the weak more beloved
to God than the weak because he he benefits other people.
poverty has an easier time in the day of judgment than the rich.
The rich have to answer for all of their wealth.
They have to be audited, right?
Well, in this life, in this life, when tax season comes around, who has a headache?
The poor or the rich?
The rich, of course, right?
So, in this life and the next life, the rich get taken into account.
So, as the their life is easier year round, except during tax time, big headache.
One guy ta came to me and he's shaking his head.
He said, "You're not going to believe this."
I said, "What?" He said, "I just wrote a check for taxes, IRS,
$400,000." I said, "I I guess I feel bad for you now.
I don't feel bad for you the other 11 months of the year, though, right?
You get envied for 11 months a year, and April 15th comes around, you wrote a
check for taxes, a ridiculous amount of taxes.
So you get 1112th of my sympathy.
In fact, less than that, right?
You do taxes for what?
Two weeks. So two out of 52, one out of 26 of my sympathy.
But point being is that that's one reason.
That is one reason that sometimes you may think that poverty because in the afterlife p
the poor get straight to paradise.
A reg a good person who's poor.
What does he what does Allah have to ask him?
What do the angels have to ask?
Nothing. Go straight to paradise.
A rich person who is good good man very rich okay come and we have to
do an audit you paid your zakat yes did you do this did you spend money
on that what is all this meat that you're eating why so much meat what are
these what's this point what was the point of that vacation why did you buy this
boat when you didn't need it and you saw there were people hungry there so he
gets audited so he goes to paradise 500 years
later so there's a cost and a there's a benefit to both sides yes Allah loves
him more he's better for the um but he will be audited more.
The other one is not so good for the um he can't benefit the um much.
Therefore, he hasn't earned Allah's love as much.
But he goes straight to paradise.
He suffered his whole life.
But also we second part of your question.
Why don't we chase wealth so much?
Because when you're looking at
eternal life and you're looking at 60
years, which one is more important to invest in?
There was one time a a
aesthetic, someone he wears a tattered phobe and he's very pious and he's praying all the
time and he's avoiding this worldly life.
So a king passes by and the king puts up his tent and he sees this
aesthetic and he says, "Aetic man, come sit with us."
And he says, "Yes, king.
What do you want from me?"
He said, "No, we're passing by.
Come and sit with us so we can take from your blessings.
You're such a pious man."
He said, "I'm not pious."
He said, "I'm no different than you."
King said, "How can you say that?
We're people of this world.
Look at all this gold, look at all this uh wealth that we have.
I feel the king is he's a sort of a decent guy.
And he's saying, you know, I feel like I want to be close to somebody like
you. You're close to Allah.
He said, well, um me and you, we both love
pleasure, but I worked it out a little differently than you, and I think you should
listen to my advice.
He said, "What do you mean you like pleasure?"
He said, "Yeah, I love pleasure, but I know that this life is leaving us, and
the next life is where the real pleasure is at.
And you may not have realized that this life is passing, and the next life is
where it's all going to be at, and you may end up suffering in the next
life. So me and you are exactly the same, except I put my eggs in the
basket of the afterlife.
I'm investing in that, and you seem to have forgotten about that.
Your faith in the afterlife is weak, so you want it all now.
Subhan Allah. That king uh in that story he like changed his life.
It's the same thing.
Uh so when you see why people aren't Muslims when or they become very religious, they
may not chase money at the same time is because
perspective. It's perspective.
One she
says Allah they never make dua for dunya.
They reach a point they never make dua for the never make dua for worldly things.
So say how how is that the case?
We're supposed to make dua for everything.
Is the answer he says the answer is like this says imagine you go to the
finest
steakhouse and you sit at the table and you order a salad.
You order a salad, what are the people in the steakhouse going to say to you
when you're at the finest steakhouse?
You're not supposed to worry about salads and stuff.
You need to order what's really there.
So these Allah has lifted the veil for them to really understand, really know, really have
in their mind what is awaiting in the next life.
Like we may know it just intellectually like we hear about it, we sometimes think about
it but ultimately we're living in the here and now, right?
And that's what matters to us.
These ah like the veil has been unlifted to them to to perceive.
They're not having a different book than we are.
Different hadith, same thing.
But in their heart they feel like it's it's right around the corner.
The afterlife is right around the corner for them to ask for this world.
It's an insult. It's an insult.